qu'on a là une occasion historique de
faire cette reconstruction de
reconversion écologique on doit
absolument faire pour éviter ce qui
s'est passé en 2008 1 souvenez vous
après la crise de 2008 on a fait une
relance brune c'est à dire en utilisant
l'énergie fossile et c'est ce qui nous a
éloignés de l'atteinte de nos objectifs
climatiques et en plus on a eu toute une
série d'économies ce qui traîne
nous on dit un peu comme le gouverneur
de la banque de france aujourd'hui qui
nous en dit à attention à faut pas non
plus trop s'endetter
il faut vite revenir au devenir sérieux
et faire leur finalement de l'austérité
budgétaire
donc moi il me semble que bien sûr qu'il
faut qu on s'endette massivement sel
peut se compare contre dans le dans le
bouquin une autre voie est possible avec
eric heyer et pascal ok mais s'endetter
pas pour faire n'importe quoi mais pour
mettre tout ce qu'on peut dans cette
reconstruction de notre économie il faut
rebâtir notre économie pour la faire
passer dans une autre situation
rénover les bâtiments investir dans les
infrastructures
bon c'est bon vraiment la honte c'est à
peu près bien tout ce qu'il faut faire
sa demande à l'argent monstrueux je
reviens ce que je disais au début
emmanuel macron disait un moment qui
avait pas d'argent magique
maintenant ya de l'argent mais sachons
l'utiliser intelligemment mettons tout
on a une occasion historique de changer
les choses de se remettre sur la bonne
route pour pour les enjeux climatiques
et puis essayons également de
conditionner tout tout cet argent pour
la relance
toutes ces aides de les conditionner à
des critères sociaux et environnementaux
[Musique]